the Supreme Court ruled 54 yesterday
that President Biden can tear down
barbed wire in Texas put up and paid for
by the state of Texas to try to stop the
historic invasion of cartel criminals
and other foreign Nationals invited and
encouraged to enter Texas illegally by
the Biden Administration four of the
Court's conservatives voted to allow
Texas to even somewhat slightly attempt
to protect its territorial Integrity
while Barrett and John Roberts sided
with Biden and the court liberals to
tear down the meager 30 miles of wire
Texas had been erecting nothing 30 miles
of barbed wire to try to stop this
unprecedented historic influx multiples
more than anything we've ever really
seen in American history and border
patrol kept cutting it down so Texas
takes Biden to court and the court rules
5'4 nope sorry Texas you're not even
allowed to protect the territorial
Integrity of your own state from a mass
influx of foreign Nationals and you know
what I'm not surprised the libs hold all
sorts of terrible disordered and deadly
things dear abortion weird sex stuff
racial discrimination you go down the
list and the Supreme Court has struck
some of that down sometimes we win on
some of those issues but this issue was
too much because more than any other
issue Mass migration is sacran to the
liberal establishment because Mass
migration in the long run is how the
Liberals plan to win on all the other
issues not just here but all around the
West wherever you look Britain Hungary
Italy Germany France America especially
Mass migration is deeply unpopular with
voters not even just the right-wing
Republicans the the conservatives deeply
unpopular with most
voters but so are the liberal Elites and
all their terrible policies so there's
only one option for the Liberals the
mass importation of new voters who are
overwhelmingly statistically more likely
to side with them it's a cynical scheme
but the Liberals in charge are dead set
on it and nothing as insignificant as
the law or the Constitution or a
conservative Court majority is going to
stop them I'm Michael nlls this is the
Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show Dana White
the head of UFC just schooled a reporter
on free speech with facts and logic and
his answer is even better I think than
perhaps Dana White knows which we'll get
to in just a little bit first though on
Court decisions got a really really bad
one yesterday the court just totally
squished Amy Barrett in particular and
John Roberts we always expect him to
squish the Chief Justice uh but in
recent years we have had some big Court
wins so it's not all doom and gloom the
biggest one of course is dobs the dobs
decision which reverses roie Wade which
saves who knows how many babies into the
future and President Biden a supposed
Catholic supposedly a member of a
religion that says that abortion is
completely unacceptable that it's not
just a mere political matter but that
the right to life is the fundamental
right on all on which all of the other
rights depend President Biden marked the
occasion by whining and complaining and
hoping that more babies will be killed
in the future he said quote 51 years ago
today Jack some hairy-legged f came down
no he didn't say that he said 51 years
ago today the Supreme Court recognized a
woman's constitutional right to make
deeply personal decisions with her
doctor decisions to murder her child
free from the interference of
politicians then a year and a half ago
the court made the extreme decision to
overturn row and take away a
constitutional right blah blah blah blah
blah the best part of this statement the
best part of this anniversary of the
dobs decision is that now it feels like
old news that's my favorite part of it
well no I guess my favorite part is all
the babies who aren't being killed but
my second favorite part is how it feels
like old news because when it happened
we were told in the leadup to that
decision we were told it's going to
cause a civil war you remember in the
leadup to it the Liberals tried to
murder Supreme Court Justices to stop
the decision from coming out they tried
to kill these guys
and Alita rather had to go into hiding a
a liberal traveled from California to
Washington DC to murder Brett Kavanaugh
and and started going up to his house
okay this was we were told this was
going to be the big issue and then it
happened and then
what everyone just kind of accepted it
and now lots and lots of babies are
alive and will grow up to be adult human
beings because of that decision and the
liberals who whine and say but it's the
law of the land it's a constitutional
right I want to kill more babies they
they seem more and more ridiculous
because not only is their Claim about
the Constitution not only is their Claim
about human life and the supposed right
to murder innocent people not only is
that absurd but even just their
historical legal arguments seems silly
because it's been a couple years now and
now it's not a constitutional right for
the vast majority of American history no
one has believed that killing a kid is a
constitutional right they didn't think
it for most of our history until the
early 1970s then we got confused for
that a little under five decades and now
we're not confused anymore and that's
that this vindicates something that I
mentioned on the show yesterday which is
this idea of the Lindy
effect the notion that the longer a nonp
perishable thing endures the longer you
can expect it to
endure so you know if a Broadway show
has run for six weeks you can expect it
to run for another six weeks if if a
Broadway Show's run for 3 years you can
expect it to run for another three years
recently Nas Nicholas talb the writer
has articulated this it comes from a
mathematician a fractalist named Beno
mandal BR it actually goes back even
further than that well it's true in war
it's true in Show Business it's true in
New York Deli and it seems rather true
in law and Juris Prudence because I was
thinking about how long row endured
don't foret row is decided early
1970s
then fast forward about 20 years and
it's up for reconsideration in the
Planned Parenthood VCC and what happens
Planned Parenthood VCC decides another
conservative squished on the court they
decide that there is a right to abortion
somewhere in the Constitution even
though they totally rewrite the
justification for it that was given in
roie Wade and then what
happens row endures for almost the same
amount of time that it had previously
endured for it almost double it goes a
little bit over doubling actually and
then it's up for consideration again and
it gets shot down in dobs so the key
here for conservatives is what we've got
to do is just build up that inera what
we've got to do is just make the dobs
decision normal just protect it at all
costs because right now it's a little
dangerous the dobs decision is kind of
fresh kind of new the libs are still
very motivated to overturn it the way
they're going to overturn it is they're
going to put liberal justices on the
court the way they're going to get
liberal justices on the court is they're
going to keep Democrats in the
presidency so it is very very important
if we want to protect dos if we want to
protect innocent little babies we need
to get a Republican president in office
soon this is a weak conservative
majority on the court obviously they
just they just rubber stamped Joe
Biden's Invasion by Foreign Nationals of
the country to give him more
voters so obviously it's a weak
conservative majority and it's only been
a couple years here very easy to
overturn that kind of a decision so we
got to get the Republican president and
right now the the Republican
presidential primary is all but over
tonight is the New Hampshire primary
we'll see what happens there's there is
still a chance Nikki Haley pulls out a
victory I wouldn't put my money on it
even if she does there's still no path
to victory for her so for all intents
and purposes Trump is the nominee and
I'm very pleased to see that he is now
pivoting even after this very rough mean
brutal primary he's pivoting to try to
bring the party together and say very
nice things about his most recently uh
vanquished rival Ronda santis before
before we begin I'd like to take time to
congratulate Ronda santis and of course
a really terrific person who had gotten
to know his wife Casey for having run a
great campaign for president he did he
ran a a really good campaign I will tell
you it's not easy they think it's easy
doing this stuff right it's not easy but
as you know he left the campaign Trail
today at 300 p.m. and in so doing he was
very gracious and he ended me so I
appreciate
it I appreciate that and I also look
forward to working with Ron and
everybody else to defeat crooked Joe
Biden we will have to get him out we
have to get him
out he's put our country at Great Peril
at Great Peril so I just want to thank
Ron and congratulate him on doing a very
good job it's a tough situation it's a
tough thing to do he just said will I be
using the name Ron desan konus I said
that name is officially
retired hold on a second wait oh you
just heard for over a year that Rob Des
sanctimonious is a terrible governor and
he's awful and he's the worst and he's
but now you're saying you like him and
he's a terrific guy and he's done a good
job and then even even jokes there at
the end he goes that name
Ronda sanctimonious officially retired
it's
done it's going to drive some people up
a wall it doesn't drive me up a wall in
fact this is one of my favorite things
about Trump because what what this kind
of a
reaction disproves is one of what I
think is the dumbest arguments against
Trump one of the dumbest lines of attack
where people say Donald Trump
is totally undisciplined he's just a
ball of emotion he takes everything
personally everything we know about
Trump shows the opposite to be
true perhaps he's undisciplined in that
he makes errant comments on Twitter back
when he had a Twitter or something but
he's not an undisciplined campaigner
he's an extremely disciplined campaigner
actually he sticks to his message at
least when he's talking about friend and
foe which some have called the
fundamental distinction in politics he
sticks to his message with extreme
discipline when when you are opposing
Trump you are the worst person in the
world you are the devil on Earth he will
bring the fires of hell he will bring 10
times the power of the sun against you
to destroy you and then the moment that
you flip over and you're on his team
again that's all done he doesn't hold a
grudge you know the evidence of him not
holding a grudge forget about even
Governor Dan santis for a second go back
to 2016 you think the Trump Dan santis
primary was bad do you remember the
Trump Cruz primary Cruz was the number
two guy in 2016 it was a vicious brutal
primary between these two men and Trump
coined the term lion Ted lyi and
apostrophe lion Ted and it was just so
so nasty and then what happens Senator
Cruz drops out votes for Trump they work
together very well and
Trump ends up campaigning for him here's
what he says Ted and I got along very
well very late into the campaign and I
said don't worry about it it's only a
question of time and then it became very
nasty and then it was over and when it
was over we' gotten a long grade no I I
like that would you if you remember he
was the last one that we really had I
mean I went very late in the campaign we
actually held a rally together laid into
the campaign I said it will end and it
did and then it got back no we're very
close we've done great on tax cuts we've
done G great on regulation Cuts now he's
really terrific not anymore
beautiful I call him Texas T no now he's
beautiful Ted now he's Texas Ted I know
the people who hate Trump are going to
say well this shows he doesn't believe
anything or he does it no it doesn't
show that he show it shows that he knows
how to campaign it shows that he sees
Politics as a team sport it shows that
he's going to be really really tough and
maybe maybe you think he's going to go
over the top when he's campaigning but
you know I think that probably applies
to every single politician but that he's
not going to take it personally a
politician who took it personally would
take his ball and go home a politician
that takes it personally would still be
talking about that terrible Ted Cruz I
hate that Ted Cruz and Ronda santz he's
mean and he said this mean thing about
me and politician who doesn't take it
personally who's not who who appears not
to take really anything
personally he treats it like business
you know it's just it's Michael Corleone
talking to Sunny when Sunny says what
you want to go kill a cop because he
slapped you around a little come on
you're going to get his blood on your
Ivy leak suit don't take it so personal
and Michael Corleone says it's strictly
business politics is a is a contct sport
okay it's a team sport it's a contact
sport as I said from the beginning of
this primary these are all big tough
guys they've all run plenty of races
none of them are little wall flowers
okay and they ran a bruising Prime Mary
Trump won and now the question is can
they come together can they not take it
personally can they come together are
they going to live up to what they've
all been talking about which is this is
about party this is about principle this
is about doing good for the American
people okay well in order to do that you
got to put personal ego aside can I
don't know it's very difficult thing to
do especially when you're you're running
a bruising primary I know it's hard but
I love that Trump does it and by the way
the minute disantis attacks him again
he's going to be back to attacking Dan
santis and then the minute Dan santis is
nice to him again he's going to be nice
to disantis and the same thing is going
to be true of haly same thing is going
to be true of Chris Christie I bet okay
it's going to be true of everybody and
from my vantage where I don't
particularly care about the the personal
lives of these people and I don't care
about their personal emotions at any
given point I just want good victories
for a conservative vision of America so
we have a good country again that is
fine by me don't take it personal keep
it business let's go out and win we got
to talk about this okay and when you
want to talk you got to check out P talk
right now go to P talk.com NES my
friends over at P talk are beating
today's inflation and making it easier
than ever to connect with the most
important people in your life P talk
gives you phenomenal coverage on
America's Most Dependable 5G Network
it's the same coverage you know and love
but for half the price of the other guys
with unlimited plans starting at just 20
bucks a month the average family saves
almost $11,000 a year could you use
$1,000 a year I think we all could as a
veteran-owned company last year alone
they raised 10 million bucks toward
veterans debt what's more peer Talk
customer service team is located right
here in the US and can help you make the
switch in as little as 10 minutes I've
spent a fair bit of time with these guys
I have a Pure Talk Phone I use pure talk
and it's great it's the best network out
there you can take it internationally
now which is really great not that
you're everyone's traveling
internationally all the time but it's
just it's a full amazing sell service
and you're just saving so much money and
these guys are on the right team and
they're doing good stuff and you should
head on over right now to peer talk.com
make the switch right now our viewers
save an additional 50% off your first
month peer
talk.com klees today obviously very very
trough tough race for Trump ahead some
Florida Republicans are suggesting that
we cover that not we I'm not a Florida
resident that the Florida taxpayer cover
president Trump's legal bills with
taxpayer funds uh this proposal was
filed by Senator Ilana Garcia in Miami
uh it doesn't specifically name Trump
this bill but the bill says that uh
legal fees incurred as a result of
criminal charges brought by a US public
entity on qualified persons would who
have been subject to political
discrimination uh would would be covered
by by state funds so obviously this is
about Trump trump is covered here Dan
santis has come out and said I'm going
to veto this if this makes it to my desk
we are not spending taxpayer money to
cover Donald Trump's legal fees I
actually think they're both right in
this instance I side with the state
senator on the general thrust of the
legislation and I agree with Governor
Dan santis that the Florida taxpayer
should not be on the hook for this I
think this should be paid for by the
federal
government this should be paid for by
the taxpayer because it's not going to
be not not what Ren sent is going to
come out of a taxpayer here okay
president Trump's legal fees we've never
seen anything like this in America they
are throwing everything they can to
destroy this man his legal fees amount
to according to him about $100 million
right
now in 2022 according to the government
accountability
office the US government wasted
$247 billion
doar just in improper payments I'm not
saying they wasted it on some stupid
study you know like lesbian obesity in
seahorses or something I mean just in
payments the government should not have
made that they did make for no reason
whatsoever they spent $247
billion Trump's legal fees are 100
million so you divide that number in
half then you go an order of magnitude
lower and you'd still have a lot of
change left
over but this should be paid for by the
government it won't it wouldn't be paid
for by the taxpayer but it would be paid
for by the government you cut truly you
could cut just even a tiny sliver of a
sliver of an Iota way should cover this
in two seconds it should be covered by
the government because otherwise you're
creating an incentive for the ruling
party to persecute the leader of the
opposition to prosecute specifically but
then broad at a broader level to
persecute to try to destroy to bury in
legal fees the leader of the opposition
and that's bad for both parties and
that's bad for the citizens if if the
ruling class can just destroy all
opposition by burying them in legal fees
when they're not running against a
billionaire or a former Bona I don't
even I don't I can't imagine Trump even
has a billion dollars anymore they've
taken his money
away that's a very bad situation that
you want to talk about a threat to
American democracy that's a major threat
to American democracy it's it has such a
chilling effect over anyone who wouldn't
want to run certainly who wouldn't even
want to work in an Administration where
the the ruling liberal establishment
afterward will prosecute you throw you
in jail or take away all your money so I
think it would be a very very good thing
for the federal government to be
accountable here and say no you know if
you're G to try to behave like some
tinpot dictatorship or some you know
stalinesque uh totalitarian state then
you know you're going to have to pay for
it at least you're going to at least
have to pay the legal fees for it
absolutely it really these
legal battles are really not about Trump
you want to talk about not making this
personal it's not about Trump what are
they over because Trump made a phone
call to the Secretary of State of
Georgia because Trump handled documents
in a similar way to every other
president in recent memory including Joe
Biden Trump less egregiously mishandled
classified documents than Joe Biden did
because Trump what because some gossip
columnist says she met him in a Bergdorf
good Goodman 30 years ago and ravished
her and she spoke sort of glowingly
about this for a while and she's
obviously pretty kooky and then now
you're going to get him are you kidding
me are you kidding
me absolutely not absolutely not got to
hold the government accountable for that
stuff now speaking of a system being
turned against normal people
Elon Musk was over in Poland yesterday
with a friend of mine there's a fell I
know by the name of Ben Shapiro they
were over there touring aitz and then
afterward they had a conversation and
Elon made the claim that
Dei is anti-Semitic the diversity exra
inclusion I you should always be always
be wary of any name that sounds like it
could come out of a George or well book
okay that's never a good sign um and uh
because it sounds like sure diversity
Equity inclusion these all sound like
nice words but but that what what it
really means is discrimination on the
basis of race uh sex and um sexual
orientation and uh and and it's against
Merit um and and thus I think is
fundamentally
anti-semitic fundamentally
anti-semitic some people saw that as a
nonse or I do not I think Elon is
totally right here but the implications
of this go far far beyond anti-Semitism
or the Jewish people which we'll get to
in one second first though we got to
talk about your feet and your shoes and
your health you got to check out gravity
defier right now go to g defy.com promo
code mk30 good Footwear is about more
than fashion what you wear on your feet
matters to your health your comfort your
well-being choosing Footwear that
provides support for your daily routine
is important and now easier than ever
thanks to G defi shoes G defy shoes are
anything but ordinary While others have
clung to shoes featuring a
run-of-the-mill memory foam Soul G defy
offers a patented Soul construction
meticulously designed to bring the pep
back in your step G defy shoes aim to
Foster healthy movement alleviate pain
and prevent further wear and tear this
is not just about absorbing shock but
don't just take my word for it explore
the multitude of reviews and
testimonials from individuals who attest
to the Miracles and the impact of G defi
shoes on their lives available on G defi
website and social media platforms your
feet deserve more than just another pair
of shoes okay and right now using my
code mk30 you will get 30 bucks off
orders of $150 or more at G defy.com
gde
f.com with promo code mk30 for 30 bucks
off your purchase of 150 bucks or more
experience the miracle that is g defy
your feet will thank me you will have
health and comfort and Fashion on top of
it g defi where Comfort meets Innovation
friends Valentine's Day is coming up
Jeremy's has the perfect gift to
surprise your better half whether you're
shopping for him or her jeremus has a
bundle for everyone from delicious
chocolate to smooth razors to the iconic
leftist here's tumbler to C celebrate
Jeremy is offering a deal you will love
get a 20% discount on all Valentine's
Day bundles that's right 20% off but you
have to act fast because this offer is
only here for a limited time go to
Jeremy
rers.us Valentine's Day Sale the best
way to treat your Valentine and
yourself Elon says diversity equity and
inclusion Dei is
anti-Semitic
totally agree totally agree with that it
is because the Jews have done very well
the Jews perform very well they succeed
at very high levels you could be the
most jew-hating
anti-semite in the world you have to
admit they've they've been pretty
successful over the Millennia haven't
they if you're a Christian surely you
would say the Jews are obviously a
gifted people what other people could
bring forth the Virgin Mary what other
people would bring forth our Lord and
savior Lord and Savior the the Lord of
Lord and King of Kings Master of the
Universe h no other people and and even
if you're less religiously inclined you
look and you see the Jews do very well
in all these industries they score very
well on IQ tests right so
Dei which says that we need to uh factor
in other things we need to prioritize
other things than Merit and work and
success and IQ and blah blah blah that's
going to be effectively anti-semitic you
you saw this in University admissions in
the US 100 years ago there were Jewish
quotas because the Jews were getting
into the schools too much but you
wouldn't say that Dei is just
anti-semitic you would say it's also
anti-asian because Asians share a lot of
those attributes as
well C certainly in affirmative action
you would say that that's anti-asian we
just had a a major court case about this
that the schools say oh yeah you've done
very well on your sat you've scored very
well you're the valorian yeah but you're
Asian so sorry we're going to give your
your spot in a university to someone of
a more privileged race than you are
ironically we're going to say they're
they're a less privileged race so we're
going to give them a special privilege
and they're going to take your spot
sorry so you'd say it's it's
anti-asian you you could make all of
those claims the one thing you can't say
is that it's
anti-white that's the weird
part because white people also do pretty
well you know historically they' done
pretty well on the statistics and they
score well on the tests and everything
but you're not allowed to say that Dei
is anti-white that's that's not one of
the reasons for which you can criticize
it anti-semitic that's okay anti-asian
that's okay anti-white not so much it's
even deeper than that it it's not only
that you can't do anything about these
policies that
explicitly discriminate against white
people because they are white in hiring
in University admissions in promotions
in
everything you can't even talk about it
you can't even mention it unless you are
willing to suffer social consequences
for it unless you work for a company
that lets you speak your opinion I work
for a conservative company my job is to
State my opinion and I have accepted the
fact that I will incur social
ostracization and all sorts of calumny
in the press for stating simple truths I
have accepted that and so in my job I'm
allowed to at least point out that these
policies explicitly and intentionally
discriminate against white people but if
you're a middle manager at some company
you can't really say that you could lose
your job if you're at a university and
you're just trying to get a good grade
and graduate you can't really say that
too openly or you will be discriminated
against if you work for the government
oh my goodness if you work for a
university and you ever said that you
would lose your job in two seconds
that that is a major political problem I
agree I just think Elon is scratching
the surface here when he says yeah Dei
is anti-Semitic it totally is and that
is one of the reasons to oppose
it and these sorts of policies are
anti-asian yeah that's true that's
that's another reason to oppose it and
it's
anti-white I consider that a pretty big
reason to oppose it
and we have a political climate right
now where you're not even allowed to
mention that it is so not only legally
acceptable to discriminate against white
people but socially encouraged to malign
white people all the time that if you
ever speak up and say hey maybe we
shouldn't you know like legally
discriminate against them you will
you'll be called a Nazi for that that
that is a actually a deeper political
problem than the Direct effects of any
of these Dei
policies say yes yes and Elon yes and
but it's it's so much worse than all
that now speaking of racial
politics Nikki haly theoretically the
last Republican other than Donald Trump
in the primary in the leadup to New
Hampshire on NBC News has played the
race card we were the only Indian family
in our small southern town I was teased
every day for being
Brown so anyone that wants to question
it can go back and look at what I've
said on how hard it was to grow up in
the Deep South as a brown girl anybody
can look at my record and see when
Walter Scott was shot down by a dirty
cop how I made sure that the Walter
Scott family didn't suffer because we
put the first body camera bill in the
country in place anybody can look at the
fact that when we had nine amazing Souls
dying mother Emanuel Church I did
something that no Republican or Democrat
ever wanted to touch
which was called for the Confederate
flag to come down because it would take
2third of the House and Senate and was
an impossible feat I don't know what
you're implying with that but what I
will tell you is saying that I had black
friends is a source of Pride saying that
I had white friends is a source of Pride
you know I really like Nikki Haley
personally
and I like a lot of the candidates in
this race and and all of the candidates
at some point will say something that's
a little hyperbolic or that I don't
quite believe and got to tell
you I'm a little skeptical that
Ambassador Haley was bullied every
single day of her life as a child for
being Brown and the reason I'm a little
skeptical
is had she not told me I would not know
that Nikki Hy was brown she's very
light-skinned her her parents are Indian
they're Punjabi so it's nor Northern
India where there were a lot of people
who are very light-skinned and I'm not
even saying that no one ever made a
comment about it when she was a kid did
probably someone did at some point maybe
someone figured it out and
but every day she was bullied for being
Brown I'm a little skeptical why is
Ambassador Haley saying this I suspect
she's saying this because she's doing an
interview on NBC and they're accusing
her of being a racist like they do to
every single Republican and this is her
natural reaction and this is the natural
reaction of many many Republicans Nikki
Haley is far from alone in this kind of
a response but I think kind of response
is ill advised because what this
response amount amounts to is accepting
the leftist
framing Nikki Haley are you racist I'm
not racist I'm
oppressed I hear this all the time one
time I was in Washington DC and the
Black Hebrew Israelites were on the
street they're the ones who scream out
and they say white people are the devil
and they're disgusting and they're
demons and they're you know the ice
people and whatever they all these crazy
racial theories and they yell mean
things at women and all this stuff and
so I was standing in line at a coffee
shop afterward there was a gal in front
of me this little white gal wearing a
North Face jacket and and she goes oh
did you hear those people out there oh
yeah yeah did you could you believe they
they called me a white devil and an
awful woman and every and I told them
this is crazy I'm a woman I'm oppressed
too and I I
couldn't I just turned away from her
when I heard that I thought lady you
took you've taken exactly the wrong
lesson from this you're trying to play a
game that you will certainly lose
first of all young affluent white girl
in a North Face in Washington DC you
you're not oppressed okay at all at all
by historical standards you are the
least oppressed human being that has
ever existed
ever we're all oppressed by sin and the
fallenness of this world but you in you
in particular
uh-uh but a lot of a lot of people think
well look that's just that's just the
culture right now is just this this it's
this race hustling oppression Olympics
and I've got to play it or I'll be
totally cast out so no no I'm actually
oppressed somehow I there are men today
I'm not I I actually remember this
starting when I was in college there are
straight guys who will call themselves
non-heterosexual they'll call themselves
queer they could they could be dating
women they could be not they've never
done anything weird never even tap
danced okay and they'll say I'm a
non-heterosexual or I'm queer because
they just need a struggle you know if
you're a rich
successful white guy you need some kind
of a struggle in in this oppression
Olympics I just think
it's it's going to make you lose from
the beginning if Nikki Haley wins by
accepting the framing that the the south
is evil and white people oppress the
brown people and it's you know this is a
systemically racist country I'm not
saying she's going to go that far but
that's what she's leaning in toward in
this kind of an answer if she does that
then even if she wins she lost you know
if we as Republicans do this this then
any Victory will be a pic Victory
because we will only have won by
embracing all of the left's premises
this is what happens when the libs or
when the conservatives rather they tout
how you know we we have
conservative activists you know you
don't listen I if you're a activist you
don't need to be with those liberals you
can vote with us well not not really
right you know like we if if you think a
man can become a woman then you're
you're not really conservative at
all no no but they support low taxes too
okay well that you know life's about
more than low taxes guys if we just
embrace all of the left's fundamental
points then we Just Surrender and even
if we're in office we're just kind of
like zombies just doing the bidding of
the left totally infiltrated by the left
possessing our minds don't do that not
not a good stuff now speaking of people
who have been attacked for being Brown
and I've I've seen it and heard it
Senator Tim Scott has just announced
some happy news he is getting
married Senator Scott is you know a
little bit older he's 58 years old many
thought he would remain a bachelor he's
obviously very busy guy he's a
politician politicians don't always have
time for a family but he just proposed
to his girlfriend Mindy He Said She Said
Yes Mindy thank you for making me the
luckiest man in the world he who finds a
wife finds what is good and receives
favor from the Lord
that's from Proverbs
18:22 as uh Senator Scott tweeted out is
great for him he's 58 she's 47 though a
lady never tells so obviously this is a
later in life marriage but a wonderful I
think it's terrific and I wish the many
many years of happiness and I've had the
pleasure of meeting Senator Scott on a
couple occasions and he's a really
terrific guy so I think that's all
great but there is a little voice inside
me a little voice of that political
cynic
crying out inside me that makes me
wonder hold on a second
here is Senator Scott in the running to
be Trump's
VP is
because not everyone is called to
marriage Senator Scott made it 58 years
without getting married and if you make
it to 58 without getting married you
probably could go the rest of your life
without getting married he's getting
married now just after he drops out of
the presidential race before the nominee
who he gorist picks a running mate even
today in our very Loosey Goosey culture
I think you probably have to be married
to be a vice presidential Contender
haven't had all that many bachelors in
American history serve as
president is this sending signals about
who Trump is going to pick we know that
Senator Scott is in contention for it I
don't know and maybe I'm not saying it's
totally cynical and they're just getting
married as a political Arrangement or
something they might love each other
very much and I think it's good to get
married so it's all wonderful but if
they're already was chatter on the vep
stakes about Senator Scott I think the
chatter has increased in volume my
favorite comment yesterday is from a 10c
who says if you're going to eat pork do
it until your mouth drips Winston Church
Hill so
true I am what I am and that's all that
I am Winston Church
Hill That's all folks Winston chur it's
every every quotation is Winston
Churchill um people who Who quote
Churchill
uh with things that he's never said in
casual conversation one usually lets it
go but if you are a speech writer
especially a speech writer for
presidential
campaign n that's not good you got to
watch out for that guys come on not a
great look I'm just I'm just saying it
just popped into my mind not nothing in
particular that I'm trying to call
out speaking of women and politics
[Music]
a
I'm there are just some things you
cannot change and you can accept that in
a spirit of resignation and you can
excel in accordance with reality which
will lead to genuine human
flourishing or you can run up against a
wall and make yourself look ridiculous
and and fail at that and and despair
because of your
failure choice is yours I guess in
America you can you can do whatever you
want in that regard but there's a
clearly a better choice than the
other now speaking of tough love Dana
White head of UFC comes
out and he destroys a reporter he didn't
he didn't hold a press briefing he held
a press beating for some reporter who
questioned what sort of things UFC
fighters can and cannot say you
obviously give a Long Leash to your
Fighters about you know what they can
say when they are up there with a UFC
microphone and you are getting into
territory of homophobia transphobia like
is there I don't give anybody a leash
well I'm saying you a leash I'm like
free
speech control what people say going to
tell people what to believe going to
tell people I don't tell any other human
being what to say what to think and
there's no leashes on any of
them what is your question I was asking
that question I'll move on though yeah
probably a good idea you that's
ridiculous to say I give somebody a
leash Free Speech Brother people can say
whatever they want and they can believe
whatever they
want good
answer
though it's a good answer like he
destroyed this reporter
though in the reporter's
defense do we really think Dana White
would be totally fine with his Fighters
saying anything we saying anything from
a UFC
platform you know if his Fighters came
out and said we need
to we need to go and behind their
parents' backs and you know he came out
and he was wearing a big rainbow leotard
while he said do you think Dana White
would be totally fine with that what if
take the weird sex stuff out of it what
if a UFC fighter came out and said we
need to support Isis we need death to
America we need to uh support all of the
terrorists around the world and we would
be much much better off forget about
that even what do you think Dana White
would support it if some UFC fighter
came out he said black people they're
the worst people in the world we should
kill them all yeah yeah absolutely
that's what I said at my
UFC press conference no I don't think so
I think Dana White would probably have a
problem with all of those things rightly
so but Dana White doesn't need to worry
about his Fighters doing that because
Dana White has cultivated a stable and
unified culture at UFC everyone is
broadly on the same page they might
disagree on this issue or that issue on
this thing or that thing but they all
share basic premises they got a same
basic attitude they all work together
and fight together they all seem to get
along together pretty well that's why it
works that is why Dana White is able to
afford his employees so much freedom of
speech because it's true Freedom these
are very disciplined guys if you're
fighting in the UFC you are a very
disciplined person okay you work very
hard you know how to control yourself
you understand understand how to respect
limits that are imposed by you on
yourself that is how American free
speech worked for most of our history
the reason it broke down is because of
the breakdown of the limits ironically
it's not that we just started imposing
limits all of a sudden it's because of
the breakdown of those self-imposed
limits or there will be order okay there
there will be some kind of cohesion
it'll either be um something cultivated
and habituated from within or it will be
imposed from without with a very heavy
hand but there will be order okay that's
our
show Tuesday baby the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code nolles and
check out for two months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans